♪ [лунає бубон і гармоніка] ♪
У шість років, я вже на весіллі грав.
Це в 1954 році чи в 1955, ось тут у мене
сусід одружувався, і я вже грав на весіллі.
Гармоніст з дитинства.
Я оце ще сміюся, що я ще нормально говорити
не вмів, а вже на гармоніці грав.
Бабуся покійна отут пришила ґудзиків 4 чи 5 і тут,
і оце я ходив і грав, як малий був.
Ось і бабуся моя.
Йдіть, я зараз оце зателефоную,
бо ще один має приїхати.
Іди, іди, ти якраз на бал потрапив.
А це якраз і ти в кадр потрапиш, Катю.
[сміється]
На обкладинку «Крокодила», як раніше казали.
Добрий день, діду допомагаєш?
Молодець.
♪ [грають на бубні та гармоніці й наспівують] ♪
Ми разом росли, наше дитинство разом було,
ми разом ходили в школу,
а після школи зустрічались на вечорницях.
Раніше ж в селі були вечорниці.
І ми зустрічались
на вечорницях
наші дівчата, однокласники,
ми разом зустрічалися,
займались гармонікою, бубоном.
Тоді учням було прийнято ходити
на роботу на літні канікули.
А зараз ми ходимо в школу мистецтв.
У Кагарлиці є школа мистецтв, ми туди ходимо.
Раз на рік 24 грудня ми даємо там,
звітний концерт робимо.
А по неділях виїжджаємо у парк.
У парку біля фонтану збираємось
беремо гармоніки, баяни, барабанчики,
колокольчики, бубони і там зустрічаємось.
Колектив був радше вуличний,
аніж той який грає в закладах.
Жили бідно і всі однакові були.
І ото сідаємо у вечері і граємо,
а асфальту ж не було на дорозі,
то як їде машина —
стоїть два часа курява після тої машини.
І в цій куряві дівчата танцюють.
Тоді губи не фарбували,
всі були здорові, босі ходили.
Вибивали ламбаду.
♪ [грають ламбаду] ♪
Бувало, я ж грав на весіллях,
то буває м'яке весілля і буває криваве.
І тверде.
Криваве — до крові мозолі.
Борис Качан...
Танцювали  ж до упаду тоді,
а гармоніка і бубон були єдиними
музичними інструментами.
Борис Качан  одружувався,
а я тільки «Весну» придбав і грав,
це криваве , я і до смерті не забуду це, весілля.
Ще гармоніка не розхитана.
А тут же,
грай, ну що ти, грай, та грай.
Якщо на весіллі гуляє 80 людей,
кожна людина замовляє як мінімум один танець
або пісню, це вже вісімдесят треба зіграти,
а вони можуть замовити по три, по чотири.
От це вам двісті сорок і триста [пісень].
По чотири дні гуляли весілля.
Чотири дні.
Субота, неділя, понеділок і вівторок.
У суботу дівич-вечір.
Ми одружувались у травні 1971-го року.
Он весільна фотографія.
На весілля наймали гармоніста і бубніста.
В суботу розписалися в Будинку культури.
Було без двадцяти три.
І в той же день був дівич-вечір.
Це те число і час,
яке я запам'ятав на все життя.
Молода приводить дружок до молодого,
а потім молодий збирає свої бояр
і йдуть в молодої до ранку гуляти.
То ми їздили в Кагарлик
у фотоательє сфотографуватись.
♪ [грають на бубні та гармоніці й наспівують] ♪
А ще раніше різдвяні свята, як святкували.
Ми в такому віці ходили щедрувати,
колядувати, ми боялися,
щоб у школі ніхто не знав.
Вітя,  а от зараз на мобільний телефон
записана музика — колядки
і в нього маленька колонка.
І під фонограму ходили колядувати.
Так Подолян говорить: ось вам по сорок гривень
за колядки і п'ятдесят гривень за рацію.
Отака маленька.
Це він сам придумав.
Кажу: «Чого ти ніякої колядки не вчиш?»
«У мене все продумано».
[сміються]
А тоді ходили, робили саморобну зірку,
тоді було заборонено.
Але ми будь-якими шляхами намагались
зустрічатись, ходити нишком, таємно,
для дітей це було велике задоволення.
Тому, що нічого іншого не було,
а зараз діти за комп'ютером,
за ноутбуком, з планшетом сидять.
А тоді всі були на вулиці.
Тоді розвиток молоді був зовсім інший,
не те, що зараз.
А зараз люди вже почали краще жити,
більші інтереси, більші знання.
Я тоді чув, що хтось їздив за кордон,
та я не чув взагалі такого.
♪ [лунає пісня «Пісня про рушник»
у виконанні героїв] ♪